I'm joined by miss Yvonne orgy you guys
know her as Molly on insecure and you
will soon see her on the big screen in
night school so we're really proud of
you
thank you okay so I'm gonna jump right
in because the last episode of in
success like it was one of the best of
the season oh this is Nate no I gotta
get on Molly because Asian Bay feels
like the perfect person for you he's
clear with his intentions he's honest
but what's going on there how is that
relationship gonna develop you know Maui
is not she's not well-versed on getting
red you know so whenever someone's
really real and like puts up a mirror to
the Molly it becomes problematic but I
think also how it is in real life with
real people no one likes to be told like
do better right the brutal truth she was
embarrassed she was embarrassed like
Coachella you saw the worst of her she
thinks like she's at a deficit you know
no one was a certain relationship what
do you think that's not at your best but
I do believe that Andrew could be the
one to let her feel BEC the layers and
allow her to be free at last free at
last thank God Almighty Molly are three
right for season four so we got plenty
of things to touch on now we see the Dro
is still a sensitive subject and it I
want to know is this going to jeopardize
your relationships moving forward well
you know I think I think they came to
closure in last week's episode where you
know Molly sees ISA and Lauren's kind of
rekindling their friendship maybe not
the romance at least the friendship
mm-hmm you know maybe this can work
me too adults can you know put aside
their differences and figure it out and
she tries that with Jo and clearly fails
but I feel like in that moment we didn't
get complete closure because we see that
Molly had a reaction in the kitchen to
finding out that he had a child
are we done seeing the end of that
conversation I mean I think at the point
of what she's having a baby with his
wife and you
I'm sorry Molly but you know I told her
I was a girlfriend but you also can't
have a girlfriend and a wife so that's
okay don't worry but yeah um I think it
was just a little bit in my offensive
you know Tiffany's on her first you know
job I'm not even on first date and so
when she finds out that Candice is
pregnant it's jarring
it's like I was really wasted my time
like creating this fantasy job it was
never gonna happen if he was never gonna
leave his wife now I'm like back to
square one
yeah you know it's like I wasted this
time I gave energy now I'm like I took
five steps back and I think that reality
that's what my I think I think we're
done with drugs
okaying I think for Molly's sake weird
cuz I hope you know what's gonna be the
babysitter oh no she was backseat to
Canada's national be back to backseat
the Canada baby knob so that chapter I
want to believe is done
please writers let it be done let it go
I think she's just at a point where a
lot of young ladies are as they're
pushed 30 just kind of like what am i
what next what that's what it's like the
GPS tracker in your life like
recalculating
I'm always recalculate she got lost
that's a good way to put it yes so we
just we need serious somebody to be like
you are here you need to get there
making u-turn okay make the nearest
YouTube you can't take somebody back
maybe I'll be passed I'll be passed me
not pass you see what ISA does to figure
out why she has been ghosted be fine
have you ever been ghosted by someone
and how far did you go to figure out
what was going on you know I'm not been
Inspector Gadget
time I mean I go back a couple posts
like okay oh I do that okay you can
still be posted but you want to send the
text back Google yourself like I'm very
I look like an African woman I bring the
whole house down like you know what stop
yourself don't that fire funny shoe I
never I liked you are you also name but
I'm just like you're messing around with
me once and it's like well it's done
you're you don't like this let you know
we thought very I think it's cuz I was
believed as the kid like I'm very quick
to be like well okay so you watched a
lot of Angela Bassett just dive it like
who who are you
so sounds like you go through a little
bit of a cyber stalking moment but not
that no yeah no Ethan was doing limo a
lot okay Lilly mousse I'm more like okay
you know what I hope you happy when you
first met your boyfriend Emmanuel did
you cyber stalk him at all or did you
guys know of one another
it wasn't even Cypress dog it was more
research okay I like whatever positive
oh it was really I just thought okay oh
you gotta be alright okay search on you
apparently not like he actually did it I
was just like he'd like he didn't know
like what I did for a living and I'm
like right he didn't know and we had a
mutual friend so like but he still was
just like that's a little better it's
better to be that way it is which is
refreshing yeah that's like he not a fan
cuz you know you don't want to be was
amazing um so he wasn't a fan which is
great which is refreshing but at the
same time there were things about my
life that were like shocking which I was
like oh that's not you didn't over the
territory way got it
but now we have to like let's go back a
little bit but I we competed Google no
how did you know that he was the one for
you um I I think we're even still
discovering that like this but I knew
that he was very different than anybody
outside not to you to even get to the
conversation of him being the one just
it was like something attracted like art
spirits it wasn't it was like not even
the physical that's deep right cuz I
mean lose them like I see them I suppose
I'm like hey Bobby okay
you know like I see the facts I said oh
my oh your face excuse
Hey oh and you floss hey good dental
hygiene yeah but there was something but
he was reading a book called the meaning
of marriage before we even met like for
the second time for like the future like
I'm not gonna put you like sometimes
when you start like dating somebody
you're like Homs reading and I'm just
like no like I was you were doing it
before he's there not enough work before
I even there was ever a lady of the
pictures it was just like and also one
of my friends was like God I want a man
who loves Jesus and reads books so the
veteran looks but it's very like I do
answer all my friend reads books yeah
like like for like leisurely like said
like edify his soul upside you all right
keep
[Music]
[Applause]